this is the ramsay show
you can be intentional about your
character you can have money and a
career you are the hero in your story
[Music]
live from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions it's the ramsay show where dad
is dumb cash is king and the paid off
home mortgage has taken the place of the
bmw as the status symbol of choice i'm
dave ramsey your host dr john dolone
ramsey personality host of the dr john
maloney show
number one best-selling author
is my co-host today
open phones at triple eight eight two
five
five two two five
that's triple eight eight two five five
two two five as we talk about your work
your relationships
your money
you
and how all of these things interact
we're glad you're here open phones again
triple eight eight two five five two two
five julia's in iowa city iowa to start
off this hour hi julia how are you
i'm so good hi you guys thank you for
taking my call i am like your biggest
fan okay we're honored how can we help
okay i'm a little nervous um
i'm 23 years old um i work as a nurse
and i'm currently on baby steps four
five and six
um i plan to start travel nursing here
in august um just in hopes to increase
my income and learn a bit more
um my question for you guys is um should
i think about buying a house or a condo
to rent out while i travel nurse or
should i just wait on that
i'd wait
yeah okay you're 23. you got time
one thing about travel nursing that we
know is you're gonna pile up a big pile
of money while you're doing this
yeah i hope so you know with that pile
of money you might make a different
purchase than you would make today
okay yeah and uh also um
renting what you know dealing with
tenants while you don't live in the town
because you're running around all over
the place
can uh leave you pretty vulnerable to a
mess
it might get
i mean it's okay to have a property
manager but let me just tell you that
there's one thing you got to know about
real estate
it all sounds good until you actually
are doing it
yeah and when you're actually doing it
there's blood and guts and
cat pee in the living room i mean it's
just there's stuff you deal with that's
real
and um i've owned real estate for 40
years and i love real estate but people
that have not owned rental real estate
or that are all enamored with getting
rich in real estate um have not figured
out that it is a lot of
stuff to deal with
i've got a property management company
that i own
that manages my properties and i'm still
asked questions almost every day
walked by one of them's desk a while ago
and she stopped me and said hey what
about this with this tenant and and i'm
not even doing the day-to-day management
but she was just wanting to know because
it was a large situation so you know
you're just gonna everything's a large
situation here you're adding hassle to
your life i would keep my life clean
and pile up some money yeah especially
if you're traveling my my guess is
you're gonna go to some city or some
state and you're gonna love it and
you're going to wish you weren't
tethered down somewhere else
that could happen yeah yeah you could
get the itch to relocate
when this is all done and because you're
going to see some cool places that's one
of the benefits of doing what i've done
all these years i've gotten to see
america's great cities
and uh and love them i mean there's a
lot of really cool places to live in
america i tell you what there are some
armpits in america last year i was on
the road more than i've ever been and
yeah there's some i just place i've
never been to incredible beautiful
places
all over the country and there's other
people places you go and you go why does
humans live here i remember thinking
this place looks like beirut you all
know we can choose you can live wherever
you want to and
that's cool whatever yeah it's yeah but
yeah it's it's there's a lot of fun out
there that we had and and a lot of uh
adventure to be had go have that okay
let's go 23. good question rochelle is
with us rochelle's in los angeles hi
rochelle how are you
hi how are you i'm doing great dave
thank you so very much for taking my
call sure what's up
okay so i have a company lease vehicle i
know don't kill me i i know i know i
know
and i wanted to find out what are your
thoughts on even though if the company
pays for the lease i am currently on my
way to
um i'm in step number
three for right now of my baby said but
my question is do i pay off the lease
or do i sell it now that the that the
market is so high
meaning like one of us is confused
okay me or you won me or you won okay
there is no such thing
as a company lease
the either the company owns the car and
they're furnishing you the car
or you went and leased a car
and you have a car allowance
correct number two i use the vehicles
underneath my name and the company gives
me
500 a month which by the way they would
give you if the car was paid for
okay they give you the 500 either way so
you don't have a company lease there's
no such thing okay
you have a leased car you have a leased
car and your company gives you money as
a car allowance for the use of your
personal vehicle
correct and if you get fired tomorrow
you've got to pay that lease out yep
correct so this is a debt you have and
um
you need to get the car paid off or get
it sold one of the two
as soon as you can as soon as you can i
mean can you can you just pay the lease
off i mean if you've have you called and
asked for the early buyout figure
um i did i haven't called yet but i did
i just looked on the statement and it's
um twenty eight thousand dollars
twenty thousand change yeah no maybe uh
let's let's go back a minute because
there's two things show up on these
statements
is that the total of all remaining
payments
um the or you're talking about like the
reviews the 28 000. now the 28 000 would
be the residual plus all remaining
payments that's a total that's a top
figure a total of payments that is not
the early buyout the early buyout is
what they will let you pay it off for
today which does not include
what we call interest but they call cost
of capital
okay i would have to call to get that
exact number but i believe um it's
closer to like thirty two thousand and
thirty three thousand no it would be
less than 28 000.
not including the final payment and the
residual amount
to buy out the vehicle
okay you're misunderstanding
okay i'm sorry okay i'm nervous sorry
that's okay let's walk through it right
quick because i want to make because
it's good for everybody to understand
that what could be showing on your
statement is one of two different
numbers the 28 000 is one of these two
numbers okay
it could be the residual value is what
you can buy the car for at the end of
the lease
okay plus
all of your payments up until the end of
the lease how long until the end of the
lease
okay i have exactly 12 months left okay
so 12 times your payment plus the
residual
does that equal 28 000
no sir it's actually more okay then the
28 000 is probably your early buyout
because that's the total obligation you
have that the more number
12 payments plus the residual value the
early buyout is as if you paid off your
car 12 months early
and it saves you 12 months of interest
on 20 30 000 bucks so it's probably
three thousand dollars less than the
total of payments and something we i
don't ever know which is showing up on
these statements unless they are very
clear with it so
if you can sell the car for more than 28
000 you probably should and then let's
figure out a way to get you a car bought
that your your company approves of so
you continue to get the um
car allowance and if you take out a
little bit of debt on that that's less
than you have now that's a good thing
[Music]
if you're considering a career in
technology i recommend bethel tech and
i'm not alone here's what brendan said
before bethel tech i was driving uber
within four months of graduating i got a
job paying 60 dollars about two years
after that i got a remote job that pays
me a hundred and thirty thousand dollars
all thanks to what i learned at bethel
tech you could be next get started today
at betheltech.net
and get 1000 to 2500
off of your tuition again it's
betheltech.net
ken coleman
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you for joining us america dr john
dolone ramsey personality is my co-host
he is the author of the best-selling
book redefining
anxiety
an 80-page quick read it is available at
ramseysolutions.com you can get it right
now it is resolution season and if
you're like most people you make
resolutions on new year's day by
valentine's day you give up on them the
gym is always empty by valentine's day
and you can't get a place in there right
now if you go to
a public gym
so if you've decided to take control of
your money this year don't do it alone
get the support get the accountability
so you make it past valentine's day the
best way to do this plug into something
is known as financial peace university
our class that has now been taught in
over 50 000 churches and locations
around america to almost 10 million
people over six and a half million
families have been through this
and uh you'll go through our proven
money plan we're going to show you
exactly how to do this it's not in
question we've got this dialed in we
know how to help you not only get out of
debt but become wealthy become a baby
steps millionaire and be outrageously
generous we have in-person classes
online classes you can do both and you
need to plug into this it's a free
trial for financial peace university for
the every dollar
premium version of the app
ties into your bank and download your
debit card transactions automatically
into your budget
can't beat that
ramsey solutions dot com slash fpu
try the free trial ramsey solutions dot
com
slash
fpu
so john i was uh listening to your
podcast and i loved no it wasn't your
podcast it was andre leadership's
podcast you're talking about new year's
resolutions yeah
and uh that was a an upbeat thing that
you upbeat thought you had and i had
never looked at it that way that it is a
wonderful
holiday that we celebrate at new year's
because it gives us all a clean slate
it's a it's a it's a mulligan like quick
can we you can do anything dave anything
in the world
and like man i gained 800 pounds i
started doing drugs whatever new year's
resolutions everyone's like great let's
let's do it right you can you can just
swipe it and let's do it again right
it's like the ultimate grace i love it
yeah ultimate grace move so it's a year
of jubilee every year right yeah but it
just reminds you
how much of your life you really do
control yes that's right and and you
know you can just decide
this is my year yeah this year i'm gonna
lose weight get out of debt i'm gonna be
nice yeah this year i'm gonna i mean
that that'd be three good ones
[Laughter]
this year i'm gonna uh whatever right i
mean you know it's you can just decide
yeah
and there's so much that in a world
that's out of control yep
there's so much of our lives our daily
lives is that are up to us now we don't
control everything i'm not i'm not
fooled by that uh i understand there's a
pandemic or was a pandemic or whatever
we call this thing now i understand
there is uh
political unrest i understand there is
racism i understand there i understand
all that i can't control any of that but
there's a whole lot of my life i can
control and i can certainly control how
i react to all of those things yes
and let's let's put into context it's
the part that nobody ever talks about
it is um
it's a few days after the new year right
we're in that first week
and i'm doing some um i'm i go all in on
these on the new year stuff i like to do
all kinds of variables and test with my
diet nutrition all this kind of stuff
i switch from coffee to tea
and dave i've had a headache the last 48
hours no way that would melt somebody's
it would melt my my bones and this is a
part of changing things that i'm
mainline coffee as a way
because tea's got plenty of caffeine in
it yeah but i'm all this little fancy
tea i'm drinking it's imported from
mexico it's a whole thing and you're
drinking like espresso or something on
the coffees right main lining
okay and so i've got all to say is this
changes you didn't just change from
coffee to tea no no no no you went from
hardcore crazy coffee to
little tea
i went from yes an f-350 dually to a
prius yes
okay um it still gets me where i need to
go but it's not near the horsepower yeah
and the headache is blowing up it is but
all it says how long how long do you
have to have the headache it's gonna be
about another day and then you know what
i'm gonna wake up and there's gonna be
like a cataract was peeled off my eyes
right and i'm gonna have this so all to
say is this change this like just aside
it comes with a cost
you've got to pay for your pay for the
way you're living whatever that looks
like well if you decide to get a i i did
a i'm 61. i did a three-mile run this
morning thank you very much
congratulations man and uh uh i've been
you know back up on my runs again and it
got warm enough today that i could
actually get out and do that instead of
just a walk and uh but you know tomorrow
i'll pay for that yeah because i have
not because i've not i've not been
running for about two weeks so yeah i'll
wake up and go oh crap i'm 61. that hurt
and we live in a culture where we we
associate pain with we must be doing
something wrong and no sometimes when it
hurts that means you're on the right
path right there's going to be that
resistance yeah what is that marine
saying pain is something leaving the
body stupid oh pain is weakness leaving
the body in the body it's not stupid
it's weakness weakness leaving the body
yeah
in some cases that's true
in the case where
i was going to ask you if you were
wearing uh if that was like a cool new
thing that no i'm the newest that's
actually what my granddaughter asked she
said papa dave who who painted your
fingernail and i said satan
[Laughter]
um and that's after i taught her some
new words
[Laughter]
oh my gosh open phones at triple eight
eight two five five two two five happy
new year lynn is in chicago hi lynn how
are you
hi dave i am better than i deserve and
uh
thankful to be in baby step seven thanks
to you and a lot of supportive friends
um my question today i work for a very
solid company that has offered an espp
and i've participated in it for the over
20 years that i've been there wow
yeah just recently discovered that
stocks doing very well just recently
discovered i don't know how i missed it
not paid attention that they no longer
have a six month look back
so you know i guess in most cases the
stock doesn't
appreciate maybe that much i don't know
in this case a closing price in july
first was 321
um december it was 415.
so
i'm thinking
uh first of all i'm 67 so i'm kind of
thinking about stopping this program
anyway
because my
um
my stock
is you know in my in my company is
getting to be like eight percent now of
my total portfolio
and my advisor has suggested that you
know like you that
i kind of cut back i'd like to
accumulate more cash i'm 67 years old
and um
but i guess i'd better like
what's up with this picture why why
like the price now is 31
more than it was at the beginning of the
plan
and they've had my money all this six
months
so like
you know that that's investing in stock
sometimes it goes up sometimes it goes
down right it's the risk you take i
guess but you've been you've been as
long as you've been investing it's just
gone up fairly steadily over the years
but certainly during this one year look
back or the six month look back
uh which gives you the benefit of either
price correct
no it does not that's what i mean they
eliminated that they eliminated them
okay so you're stuck with the prices the
price is the price
so here's the thing here's the thing
how we got here doesn't matter to make
this decision
the way we make this decision is
what are we going to do going forward so
how much money is in this company stock
what's it worth
it's about fifteen thousand okay not a
lot of money all right so let's put
fifteen thousand dollars cash in the
middle of your kitchen table do you see
those hundred dollar bills laying there
in your mind right now oh yeah okay now
and let's look at the stock price today
what it is today
and you know some things about this
company
because you've been around in a long
long time
are do you want to invest
15 000
into this company
and do you want to continue to invest in
it monthly on a purchase monthly
purchase plan based on what you think
it's going to do
going forward going forward is the only
thing we can make the decision based on
the past
is um it's worthless except to help us
predict the future
so what do you want to do are you going
to buy more are you going to buy less
um i don't think i'm going to buy more i
think i'm actually a great idea for a
friend suggested since i get to my
churches
i tied to my church
um i'm going to take some of it and give
it uh so i'll have
no tack yeah that's a good way to do it
you can do a stepped-up basis on that
gift
and um to the value and that'll give you
a great write-off that's a good use for
it
some charity work with it's wonderful
well you're sharp you're on top of it
you're gonna make a good decision i
trust your decision and i think it's
going to be fine and the 15 000 is not
bothering me a bit one way or the other
i think you're going to be okay
[Music]
if you're not using puretalk for your
wireless you're paying too much puretalk
gives you the same great 5g coverage on
the same 5g network as one of the big
guys for half the cost the average
family saves over 800 a year go to
puretalk.com and choose the affordable
plan that's right for you with their
30-day risk-free guarantee you have
nothing to lose go to puretalk.com and
enter the promo code ramsey to save 50
off your first month
[Music]
great
[Music]
[Music]
dr john deloney ramsey personality is my
co-host today as we talk about your life
and your money
time for a debt-free scream at least
according to my screen that's what it
says steve and vicky are on the line
from olympia olympia washington hey guys
congratulations on your debt freedom how
much did you pay off
we paid off 96
714 dollars way to go
how long did this take you
24 months 24 months and your range of
income during that time
uh we started out at 140 went up to 170
and we're back down to 140. cool what do
y'all do for a living
i'm a registered nurse yeah i'm a
mechanic all right very cool what kind
of debt was your 97 000
it was our house
talking to some weird people
i love it way to go you guys what's this
house worth
uh probably 550 600 maybe
i love it and it's all yours it's all
ours
how does it feel to not have any
payments in the whole world it's crazy
yeah that's amazing
i thought people who paid off their
houses were all uh rock stars and movie
stars not mechanics and nurses
does that feel weird
um yeah the first the first month with
no house payment was like what do we do
with all of this and then of course we
hooked up with the smart investor pro
and we're ready for retirement now wow
eddie uh so how much have you got in
retirement now oh not enough we have a
lot of work to do but we're going to
catch up we have lots of time we're uh
i'm 50 and he's 51. oh you got plenty of
time you're gonna do just fine okay all
right so now you fill that up and you
become everyday millionaires or by baby
step millionaires right that's right i
like it congratulations you guys
so very cool and we wanted to say thank
you for
being there
you made it all really happened
well we're honored i appreciate that you
made it happen i just showed you how i'm
so proud of you so tell us the story
what got all this started 24 months ago
oh goodness it started a little bit
before 24 months ago i had
finally after 19 years paid my master's
degree off and um the month after i paid
it off
my friend was here from
san antonio and she asked if i'd heard
of you and i said oh yeah i listen to
him when i'm mowing the lawn i listen to
his podcast but you know he doesn't
really
doesn't really matter to us we don't
really owe anything except our house and
uh
and she said well my husband and i just
paid off our house why don't you take
financial peace university and and do
that too and i thought oh my gosh we
could pay our house off
my friends challenged me to drink
another beer and your friend challenged
you to pay your house
that's amazing
we enrolled in financial peace
university and followed the steps and
and it was just
like you say it was game on we were
ready and we lit it up and did it
i love it you guys are amazing
congratulations thank you wow all right
now that people hear this and they just
showed your your crazy looking chart i
love it
i love your chart on the youtube channel
and um
and beautiful mind stuff going on there
and uh so
when people see that and they hear you
paid off your house
and you're 50 years old and you're a
nurse and a mechanic
and you know you make 140 170 to 140.
what do you tell them the key to getting
out of debt is how did you do this
stay focused
and believe that you can do it
yeah and and i think also that budget oh
goodness sakes was that budget uh you
know it was hard for a while it was you
know we can't afford that we can't
afford that but you know what now we can
so it was totally worth
it was worth the work for sure no the
truth is you could afford it but you
couldn't afford it and hit something
that was more important to you that's
right you're right yeah you were making
choices intentional choices yeah and
that that's the power of this the budget
just doesn't tell you what to do it just
makes you realize what you're doing
yeah you're absolutely right i love it
i'm so proud of you guys you're amazing
all right now that the house is paid off
you went and saw the smartvestor pro
you're gonna start saving for retirement
but what's the first big thing you're
gonna do to celebrate
oh my gosh we haven't even gotten that
far yet i'm looking at him going well
we just put a new propane stove in the
house i mean
oh you saw you celebrate big
come you go big girl i'm just telling
you i got a stove yeah
that's nice not what i'm talking about
honey
we'll play on something dave i promise
all right i want you to have some fun i
want you to do something to you know
drive this stake in the ground and stop
because you just did something very few
people ever do and a whole lot of people
don't even believe you can do to steve's
point uh one of the big things you got
to do to be able to pull this off is you
have to actually believe you can do it
right right yeah you guys are amazing
well we're going to send you a copy of
the book baby steps millionaires because
that is definitely the next chapter in
your story you're going to be there
before you know it with these numbers
this is pretty incredible
and be able to retire with dignity and
spend all of your 50s and the 60s and
the rest of your life in a paid-for
house
life is really good also send you a copy
of the total money makeover you can give
it away and you can be the friend that
disrupts your friend when they're mowing
the grass and says pay off your house
thank you i like it i like it i love it
i love it i love it way to go you two
your rock stars your heroes
steve and vicky olympia washington 97
000 paid off that's house and everything
at 50 years old did it in 24 months
after they knocked off her master's
degree
debt and 140 000 income to up to 170
back to 140. count it down let's hear a
debt free scream
three
two
one
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
just like that a half a million dollar
paid for house and again as i'm just
thinking of this as a citizen dave i
want my mechanic to not have a house
payment
i like it because then when i pull in
and the mechanic can say you don't need
that man
and he's not thinking uh you don't
really help my house payment you know
what i mean yeah yeah i've accused
lawyers for trying to fund their kids
college
oh man fund off of lawyer fees oh my
gosh i just i love it man yeah we're not
getting anything done here but sending
the loggers kids to college i've said
that a bunch
it's a real thing man
that's so great i'm a nurse with
andy for what if you're sitting out
there thinking well i'm just uh
feeling the blank job right i'm just a
teacher i'm just a just a
mechanic i'm just a nurse i can't you
can
no you definitely half a million dollar
house that they don't owe anybody
anything for boom boom boom boom boom
and i gotta tell you man there i i'm
gonna turn into a positive thinking
junkie before this is over this whole
thing of
if you think you can or you think you
can't you're right you're right henry
ford quote the power of belief the power
of faith is scriptural uh it lines up
and it's the opposite of what everything
on the internet is telling you right now
about your life they tell you you can't
do anything
everywhere there's hate everywhere
there's toxins flying around in the
mental space and you've got to be
careful if you keep feeding your brain
manure your brain's going to be manure
because it's garbage in your body manure
your relationships your work will be
manure everything will be and and the
opposite of that is
what was the key to getting out of debt
steve
believe you got to believe
what's the key to becoming a baby steps
millionaire well you can't do it cause
of racism you can't do it because of
sexism you can't do it because the rich
inherit all the money only wealthy
people only give me millionaires inherit
money which means you don't know nothing
about nothing when you say stupid stuff
like that
because it indicates that you don't
understand the power of belief number
one
and the data just the facts the data the
data is there to tell you very very
clearly that you're wrong but
and we've got all the proof here and put
it all in the baby steps millionaire's
book is coming out next week to prove it
to you but i did a whole chapter in
there on belief because of this because
it gets so
jacked up that you know
you know why the second million you ever
heard making the second minion's easier
in the first
because you know you can because you did
it yeah you know it's like riding a bike
a second time huh first time you wrote
it you're like oh my god
the second time you're like oh i've done
it before yeah
same thing same exact thing baby way to
go stephen vicki it's awesome they're
gonna be so wealthy
what great people too this is the ramsay
show
[Music]
dr john dolone ramsey personality is my
co-host today open phones at triple
eight eight two five five
two two five kelly was it 58 million
that we had paid off in debt free
screams last year we're doing that from
memory yeah okay last year on the air we
had 58 million dollars worth of debt
free screams uh as of our last debt free
screen moments ago where uh broke the
first million for this year million 89
000 so far this year already wow and
we've been on the air three days
there we go so uh just let you know
we're gonna beat 58 million next year at
that rate so just just go ahead and
kelly set yourself a goal we got to we
got to break 60 million and it's on you
to make that happen so yes she lines up
the debt-free screams so if she just
makes sure it happens i like what just
happened there that's pretty good it's
delegation
[Laughter]
the problem is i just turned her loose
too so just keep that in mind
open phones at triple eight eight two
five five two two five alex is in
houston texas hey alex what's up
hey nothing much dave and john hey so
i've got this question that i haven't
been able to find a good answer to
and essentially it has to do with
early retirement and how best to fund
that the mutual funds
or or however that best looks as to be
able to access it you know when you're
50 55.
oh so you need an income prior to the 59
and a half to be able to cash out your
other stuff
yes sir got you okay how old are you now
i'm 26 right now okay
and um
so you are debt free
debt free um currently cash flowing my
wife's college
but trying to get a few things lined up
uh once that's over and and kind of hit
the ground running okay
well my point is i want you to work the
baby steps before you worry about the
answer to this question so that this
this discussion
is fine to have but i want it to be a
little bit theoretical for right now
okay
okay i don't want you to take your eye
off the ball and go work on this stuff
we're getting ready to talk about until
you've worked the baby steps
in other words you you're jacking up
your
regular retirement first
because we don't need to talk about
retiring early and you have no money in
your 401k or roth iras you follow me
yes sir okay now
two ways that you can do that once you
are debt-free house and everything and
you're starting to really load up your
regular retirement funds and you want to
do some additional investing that you
can access earlier before 59 and a half
one is you can begin to save and pay
cash for real estate and obviously real
estate throws off an income from the
first day if it's income producing real
estate which is the only comment i'm
suggesting right now but you save up and
buy a rental house you save up and buy a
a small apartment complex or a little
office building or something
and you begin to work that way that is
obviously money you can access
at any time
and you you have to access it the rent
that comes off of it it's not optional
the second thing you can do
is you can invest in
uh what are called low
turnover mutual funds
now the way a low turnover mutual fund
works is they don't turn the stocks in
the mutual fund over they don't sell
anything it's a buy hold
strategy by and large
so if you have a five percent turnover
ratio that means they only sell five
percent of the holdings a year does that
make sense
yes sir and that if it if they don't
sell it and you don't sell it it's a
capital gains growth
meaning that you have the growth
but you don't pay any taxes on it until
you actually sell some of it so an
example of that that's easy to do is an
s p 500 index fund
and so i dump some money in an s p 500
index fund almost every month i've got a
good deal in there
as my overflow funds
because that money then grows and i
don't pay any taxes on the growth or
hardly any
until i actually pull it out and use it
and if i've left it in there at least a
year when i pull it out and use it i pay
capital gains rate on the taxes
rather than ordinary income rate on my
taxes so in in most people's cases that
be 15
instead of 30 or 40 or whatever your tax
rate is okay my case i make too much
money so my capital gains is way more
than fifteen percent but
um so because i'm rich and i must be
punished and that's how that's how the
thing works these days but
uh but anyway the the
the point being that you're getting two
benefits here one you're not paying
taxes until you take it out and then
b when you do take it out you're paying
less taxes
okay
so the low turnover mutual fund works no
matter how much you take out exactly
whatever you take out is going to be
taxable
on the gain
so it works like it works like this easy
way to remember it is let's just take a
single stock let's say you bought a
stock of a share of home depot and i
don't even know what home depot sells
for okay i'm just making this up
but um
you bought it for fifty dollars
and next year it's worth sixty dollars
you do not pay any taxes on that ten
dollars in gain
unless you sell that stock and you'll
pay taxes on the ten dollars then
but if you hold it ten years
and it goes up from fifty dollars to 150
dollars you don't pay taxes on that
hundred dollar gain
until you sell that stock
and what we're doing inside that low
turnover mutual fund is there's a whole
bunch of home depots in there they're
just holding them all
and they're all going up up up up up up
up up up up up up up up up up and you're
not selling them and so you're getting
the value going up without paying any
taxes until you do sell it and you only
pay taxes on the amount it went up and
the amount you sell and it's only at
capital gains rate so it's at a reduced
rate and it is uh gives you a delayed
a tax deferred growth the capital gains
growth on it and that's that's what a
whole lot of people do for their what we
call bridge
uh investing to make the bridge between
50 and 59 and a half work
dave
i hear this question a lot from people
in the early 20s what do i have to do to
be able to retire sooner rather than
later
my initial pushback on that question is
always
why are you already planning on what
what is it about the life you're setting
up for yourself that you can't wait to
do something else with it yeah and
agreed is that a great am i off because
there's something about like man if you
love coaching then be the best coach you
can be and love coaching and i don't i
don't have any plans to quote unquote do
nothing you know what i mean that's not
one of my life goals
i like i like what i do
i've always liked what i do to your
point if that young man is
uh wanting to do this his motivation is
because he hates his job today right but
go and change the job man yeah get ken
coleman's book paycheck to purpose and
start making plans to go do something
you love and you'll make more money
anyway so if you're doing something you
love if that's the point
i have already done the flip and
sometimes it's wrong when i've done it
because i'm when i hear people say
retire
what they're really saying is i want
wealth that i can i want to be able to
access some of my wealth there you go
okay before i'm 60 gotcha before i'm 59
and a half and so that's how i
interpreted the question okay and if i
was wrong and you were right then your
advice is actually correct because i
don't know i didn't ask him that i
didn't i didn't think about that
question that's i just i just flew you
know how can i get to some of my money
before i'm 60. uh okay because i don't
want it all kind of trapped over there
in retirement and he's already he's
running spreadsheets this guy's running
spreadsheets that's exactly right he's
he's 26 and he's projecting he's nerding
out right and uh because i know him
because i do it all the time so i did it
all the time when i was here how quick
can i get out of this this quote-unquote
life thing right now yeah how quick can
i get to make get access to some of this
money the live like no one else portion
of dave said yeah yeah yeah yeah if
that's what he's saying then i'm fine
with it but if he's saying oh i hate my
job and i can't wait to figure out a way
to not have to do it anymore
that's what retirement means that's when
i look at the retirement data and that's
where people just die yeah right or
their bodies fall apart yeah man and so
it's time to go and start doing
something set up the life you love yeah
something and you don't have to make
less money to do it either oh you just
get king coleman's book and you learn
the clear path that he's got there it's
very clear on exactly what to do we talk
about in the ramsey show all the time
but you're you're exactly right so
it's uh i haven't thought about that
chris hogan was ramsey personality did
that book retire inspired we kept
dealing with that
a lot that you know one of the things
chris used to say is beautiful saying
and i'll steal it uh is uh
uh
retirement is not an age it's a number
yeah yeah
and and really what we're saying there
is
wealth is a number yeah
accessible accessible that i can get my
hands on so it's a good good
clarification
to talk through
love it love it love it
open phones at triple eight eight two
five five two two five that puts this
hour of the ramsey show in the books
[Music]
hey it's kelly associate producer and
phone screener for the ramsay show if
you would like to do your debt free
scream live on the show make sure you
visit the ramsay show dot com and
register we would love for you to come
to nashville and tell dave your story
[Music]
this is the ramsay show
[Music]
you can be intentional about your
character you can have money and a
career you are the hero in your story
[Music]
live from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions it's the ramsey show where
debt is dumb cash is king and the paid
off home mortgage has taken the place of
the bmw as the status symbol of choice
i'm dave ramsey your host you jump in
we'll talk about your life and your
money open phones a triple eight eight
two five five two two five that's triple
eight eight two five
five
two two five dr john deloney ramsey
personality as i said is my co-host he
is the best-selling author of the book
redefining anxiety also host of uh the
most popular and exploding podcast
around here other than this one at the
ramsey networks called the john the dr
john dolone show where we talk about
relationships and boundaries and
all kinds of fun stuff and some of it's
a little crazy but most of us just
regular people trying to figure out how
to make their way through life
i think what i'm finding out personally
is the convergence of the things that i
thought were crazy it's it's everybody's
going through something yeah everyone's
going through something yeah there's
there's some stuff out there but i mean
some of the topics are weird yeah but
most of them are just like yeah i kind
of get that and me too so tell me about
that john you know exactly yeah so
speaking of which we always say around
here
that
personal finance is 80 behavior it's
only 20 head knowledge so i stumbled
into the fact i backed into the fact 20
years ago in this 30-year journey
that
if you don't have your marriage
working on the same page
the chances of you becoming wealthy and
getting out of debt are very low
it's worse than that
if you aren't controlling your behaviors
your maturity level is not increasing
emotionally
spiritually
your ability to build wealth and hold on
to it
is ridiculously low right and actual
data points to that the extreme of that
is
i have worked in the financial crisis
world now off and on or you know
indirectly directly for 30 years
and 100
of the addicts
that i have ever met
end up broke
it's just a matter of when
they either break away from the
addiction
and the behaviors associated with it or
they end up broke because the addiction
eats their life
alive from the inside out it eats up all
their relationships it eats up all their
money it eats up their career and their
ability to make money
it eats up everything eventually it
takes hold and it is the
god that demands minute by minute day by
day worship right and steals your life
from you
addictions are the extreme of
misbehavior
but 100 of the misbehavior whatever we
want to call that if you want to uh call
it an old christian word we'll call it
sin
if you want to call it just
things that don't help you personally
that are harming you personally but feel
good in the moment then you get in all
kinds of garbage here
and so and what we've seen is an
explosion of those things
whether they're to the addiction level
or not
because of our access to the internet
and the resulting uh industry explosions
around uh gambling yep online gambling
number two addiction now in the world
wow approaching number one
and destroying families for obvious
reasons destroying their finances for
obvious reasons
uh and uh because it is the ultimate in
arrogance that you think you're gonna
win
and uh number one addiction
uh porn yep and online porn i mean when
i was a little kid porn was a was a a
playboy hidden under a rock in the woods
exactly you know
uh
and are under somebody's some kid's
mattress in the neighborhood
that's not porn anymore no and every
playboy ever printed is on somebody's
cell phone right by their bedside table
right well and it's boring compared to
right yeah the other stuff now i mean
it's just bizarre and let me just tell
you guys if you don't know this it's the
number one addiction and more money is
spent on pornography now in america than
all professional sports including nascar
combined
more than spent on nfl tickets
nba tickets
anything added together and we know what
it's doing to their lives
we know it's not just being approved
that's not the point the point is
there's a behavior mechanism here that
is being destroyed in people's lives
and so when you pull up on the internet
and we do research here all the time on
the internet because we're always
utilizing the internet for marketing and
for connecting to you guys for good
stuff
but
by far 5x the number one search is porn
yep
by far
and the first 50 things that are
searched on the internet
almost none of them have anything to do
with you winning right are you doing
anything you doing it they're all you
controlling you
fighting donald trump yeah misspellings
of joe biden made the top 50.
now that's funny i don't care who you
are uh the uh uh you know porn triple x
free porn nfl scores yeah gambling
scores uh nba scores
uh in a uh
college football scores nothing wrong
watching football nothing wrong with it
you know with some of this but but you
it's all about you
escaping somewhere watching someone else
be successful that's right i will never
forget i went to see uh
i forgot the movie it was a jazz movie
james probably knows what it is uh la la
land yeah and i went to all the movies
beautiful movies it was great with me
and my wife and i walked out and i was
walking towards our car in the parking
lot and i thought
i just
spent 30 bucks in two hours of my life
to watch another couple
go have a romantic
arc in jazz clubs and dancing when i
could have just taken my wife dancing
and i never forget thinking i'm
outsourcing why don't i go get a group
of guys to go play basketball why do i
pay money to watch other people play i
don't even know them why would i put
another man's jersey on my back that
doesn't make sense get some guys go play
softball and i realized in on the way to
my car out of that park out of that
movie theater
i'm outsourcing my entire life
pornography is just an outsource of
intimacy opioids is an outsourcing right
it just keeps going and going and going
and at some point we have to plug back
in or the teeter-totter hits for us
right the economy collapses we're going
to stare each other in the face and be
like oh hey i haven't seen you in a
while right we're gonna have to deal
with it at some point and man if we
could plug back into our own lives man
what would that be like yeah just don't
watch a fishing show go fishing
right yeah go fishing don't go watch
your golfing don't watch don't watch
golf as a princess please just in
general don't watch golf but go outside
go play golf go go play golf go play i
know you suck at it i do too go plug it
go play golf
i'm talking to the people out there
you're really good i'm not that good but
they they i mean i just learned how to
play but the uh you know like it's this
but go learn how to play deuce
down do something you know
instead of spending eight million
dollars on a
5 000 square inch television yeah put a
golf simulator in your basement yes
which by the way one of our guys here
did the other day built it out himself
wow so the point being guys
you you think you can separate these
behaviors or these misbehaviors
from your lack of success in your money
and your career and you can't they're
the cause it's all intertwined
they're the cause that's how it works
so you're not going to win if you keep
uh
misbehaving i'll just leave it at that
if you keep running from your life yeah
don't outsource
wow that's good i like that's a good
word don't outsource
this is the ramsay show
[Music]
uh
[Music]
still on baby step number one huh
how'd you guess
with health care costs rising learn how
christian healthcare ministries can help
you make the most out of your budget
visit
chministries.org budget don't worry it's
worth it
[Music]
[Music]
dr john deloney ramsey personality is my
co-host today open phones at triple
eight eight two five five two two five
one week from thursday just nine days
away
on january the 13th we have a huge event
called building wealth in 2022. the
event is so loud over 1500 people will
be joining us live in the audience
and of course in addition to that we're
going to offer it now since it's sold
out as a free
live stream and over 60 000 of you
signed up for the free live stream it's
going to be me speaking about wealth
building
in 2022 rachel cruz will be with me
george campbell will be with me and
we're going to talk about not only some
of the things that are going on out
there in the real world today like what
is the real story on crypto what is the
real story on nothing down real estate
what's the real story on nfts what's the
real story and what's the real story on
how to really really build wealth and
we're going to unpack that for you and
you really ought to tune in again it's a
free
event this next thursday night one week
from tomorrow for most of you january
the 13th don't miss the opportunity if
you want to register for the free live
stream which is the only way to watch it
go to ramsey solutions dot com slash
wealth ramsey solutions dot com slash
wealth and of course next week is the
week we also launch the new book baby
steps millionaires and you can still get
it on pre-sale at ramsey solutions while
you're there at 20 bucks andrea is with
us in denver hi andrea how are you
hi good how are you better than i
deserve what's up
thanks for taking my question i'm a
little nervous so bear with me no
troubles um
so my husband and i started baby step
two and since mid-october we paid off um
15 grand on one debt which is my car
very good but the baby steps have caused
us to look at our mortgage and we
realized that we're just over that 25
mark but on a 30 year
and even before this he and i have been
going back and forth and we just cannot
seem to make a decision on
whether we actually want to stay in this
house because we're a little bit scared
of the real estate market but some of
the things that we go back and forth on
is
we own a little bit of land
which he believes it might be a good
investment
for development down the road
but one of the other things is we're
also 30 minutes away from everything in
town um
and to make the house what we really
want we would have to put about 160 000
into it
um and so we're just kind of stuck on on
what to do and i i wanted to get your
advice
what's your household income
it's 110 right now
okay the way you said right now makes me
think it's going to change
yes he's looking into he's in law
enforcement he's looking to promote
which would add about twenty thousand
dollars um to the income and that would
be which would make you
which make you easily within your 25
then
um i'm not 100 sure what a 25 would be
on a 15 year close enough though i mean
you're not going to be far off so okay
okay so then the question comes where do
you want to live and when
yeah i hear this is less of a confusion
you want to move and he doesn't that's
what it sounds like
that's a little bit of what's what's
there yes that sounds like it's all of
it
um yeah i go back and forth a lot um
some days i really want to move and be
closer to town because i'm driving my
kids back and forth between school and
activities i feel like i'm in the car
you know a couple hours every day so the
piece of land is uh you own it free and
clear
no we owe a 360 on it
how much acreage is it
um it's 13 acres it's right outside of a
little town that's really developing
it's an easy question you don't go back
and forth because is it closer to town
or further from town
it's 30 minutes away from our church
school and our family what are you now i
feel like i'm
i'm 30 minutes away from that we have a
tiny little town that doesn't so you're
an
now and this makes you 30 minutes out
no you're 30 minutes out and this makes
your three minutes out
three we are 30 minutes away from
everything like our school in our church
today but there's a small town today yes
okay what would you be if you were on
the land
it is the 30 minutes
the town
they're both 30 minutes away from
everything
no the town that's developing it's about
five minutes from here but right now we
don't have the school and the church and
everything else so they're just now
kicking up development which is why my
husband would like to stay on it until
development comes our way and we're here
for you on the property now
we are on the property now yes oh that's
why i was confused i thought it was two
pieces of property you live on the 13
acres
yes oh crap okay here's where i'm
confused
move to town
yeah charlotte
why won't you just say what you want to
do something is keeping you from saying
what you really want to do well her
husband thinks she's a big-time real
estate developer and she don't want to
spoil his dream that is true
yes
there is a baby and she's sick of
driving kids through traffic because he
wants to develop something that's
probably about five years too early way
too early
and if he had 360 thousand dollars in
cash to buy it i'd say buy it but he
doesn't so no you're selling you're in
debt sitting you're playing real estate
speculator instead of building a home
or everything slows down this little
tiny town out there just goes
kaput for the next 15 years and sits
and y'all are on a worthless piece of
land yeah sell it yeah shall it move
enjoy your life
you know
like it it sounds easier what's the
haven't got anything to do anything to
do with the 25 issue though yes it's got
to do with you don't want to live there
and you're trying to come up with math
reasons to tell your husband why you
want to move
is that fair
um i think that the 25 thing just made
us go
you re-look everything there you go um
okay well it's tight
and it's far away
okay
and and that's on one side of the scale
on the other side of the scale is we
might make a bunch of money if we split
this up into lots someday
yeah but you're not real estate
developers you're building a family
right now and you're in law enforcement
don't be a real estate developer move
okay
it's just there's a lot listen real
estate development's a pain in the butt
i do a bunch of it it's a pain in the
butt
you're dealing with city people and
codes people and planning people and
oh my god it'll make you want to shoot
yourself it's not all so there's a rock
underneath the drill you're digging
that when you hear that sound it's 1500
bucks an hour
okay so uh yeah i'm in tennessee where
there's a lot of rock but yeah
yeah this is you're trying to combine
too many different things here yeah um
you caught that john good catch and
trying to use one set of metrics to just
say what's in your heart and which in
your heart is you want to move yeah yeah
if you bought the exact same
math
closer to town i'd be okay with it yeah
because his income the life you want
yeah his income's going up and you got
your life back you're not driving 30
minutes to everything yeah you're um you
moved out to the country
and uh time to move back to town
that's it it's not as much fun as it
sounds i moved out to the country into
this nice subdivision but it's way out
in the middle of nowhere and i feel like
country people might you know when i was
a kid country my family and stuff they'd
be like we have to get a list because
we're going to get you know getting a
trip up to town oh hey you got to get
ready to go to town live out the woods
and that's you have to get ready to go
do you have to get ready to go do
something we're going to like going to
the markets an event yeah and the fact
that i just said to the market makes me
feel like that's like i've been there
too long yeah you opened your mouth your
old man just came out exactly you don't
go to the grocery store when you live
out there
you'll load the kids up yeah i'm telling
you yeah it's fine there's nothing wrong
with it
i did not anticipate that part of this
last move yeah because that that home we
had was was too much and it was a great
opportunity to sell it but it was right
in the middle everything yeah i mean i
could just you know like fall off the
hill of the house and i was right in the
middle of everything
not now i'm playing my gas station trips
only thing i'm close to now is this
office
i just come to work a lot
we all love that everybody don't we yes
we do we'll be sarcastic about working
here come on man i love i love working
here
and also
i love it i love every second of it you
just had to do the old job thing
it's just classic it's a throwback oh my
gosh
this is the ramsay show
[Music]
[Music]
dr john bologna ramsey personality is my
co-host today open phones at
825.5
maggie and curtis are with us in
cincinnati it says on my screen you guys
are debt-free congratulations
thank you
welcome how much did you pay off
we paid off 63
989
excellent how long did that take
15 months wow and your range of income
during that time
uh we made about uh 90 and ended at 100.
cool what do y'all do for a living
i am a skincare and beauty specialist
for a major cosmetics company and when
we started our debt-free journey i
picked up freelance makeup artistry and
i also stay at home during the day with
our three kids cool good for you that's
cool and i am a plant supervisor at our
water treatment plant here very good you
have the best skin of any of you and
your co-workers don't you
that's incredible
oh my gosh all right so how what kind of
debt was the 64 000
it was
credit card debt and student loans
okay all right so you're kind of normal
no car payment
no car payment
luckily those are kind of old and have
been paid off for a while i got it okay
all right so what happened 15 months ago
that started you guys on this ramsey
journey
yeah so um
we knew a few people who spoke highly of
financial peace university
and so we actually attended one at a
church a few years ago
and
um curtis was the one who got hooked on
it and
it really got to the point where i i
thought you had moved into our house
dave i mean your podcast was on 24 7.
whether
we were at home in the car cleaning it
didn't matter
you were on
um he's read every single book i mean it
was literally like you were a roommate
but you were living rent free so a
roommate from hell though
[Laughter]
and so uh during that time of him being
all in with it i actually had some debt
that he did not know about so
yeah we we really weren't making much
progress and so i had been hiding some
credit card debt from my past and i
thought i could handle it on my own i
saw it as my problem to deal with and
you know i was embarrassed about it so
once i became honest with him about it
we were able to work as a team track
what we were doing in every dollar
we were winning with the debt snowball
the magic really started to happen and
15 months later here we are
i can see if you're hiding that how me
being everywhere on every coffee table
you could really resent dave ramsey
yeah yeah i don't blame you i understand
that so how much credit card debt were
you hiding
it was about thirty thousand whoa
from from uh how long have you all been
married
so
actually it's our um 10-year anniversary
today okay happy anniversary so you've
been hiding this you've been hiding this
inside the marriage for a long time
yeah tell me about the conversation when
you finally came clean what was that
like
that happened
yeah it was it was hard he
he knew about some of it but i just
wasn't honest about the amount
how much it was
so he saw that we were making payments
on the credit cards but he didn't know
that it wasn't paying the balance down
and
so i was trying to pick up
what
was left of it
and i just i couldn't keep up with it
and
um started to notice just my my attitude
um was different just around the house
and around him and you know any
conversation about money i just like ran
away from secrets will take your soul
right
yeah yeah yeah so i think um
reached a breaking point and it was a
really
hard conversation a lot of tears um
but
happy happy we did it good for you guys
curtis what's it feel like when your
wife sits down and says i have 30 000
worth of credit card debt i've been
lying about
uh it it knocked the wind out of me i i
when we first after fpu
i and we started on this i could kind of
tell she was holding back
for some reason and i couldn't figure it
out
and
i think after we
paid off a credit card that i did know
about
and i was kind of excited about the
progress we made
and the extra money we could snowball
into the next debt
that's when she broke down and it all it
all came out and uh
it took a couple weeks to kind of
recover and and uh
kind of go from there and actually
devote ourselves to the plan and her
actually finally being all in with the
plan yeah
and now maggie curtis doesn't sound like
the kind of guy that blows up when you
got this information he just kind of
looked at you sad
yeah he he's a a man of few words but
i don't want to make him angry
okay
was he angry that night
oh yes yeah okay
okay well we we always we say around
here you get to a point where you can't
you can't
you can't just do away with what
happened yesterday all you can do is
deal with the moment right now and deal
with what tomorrow's gonna look like and
so uh
it took a long time and i wish i hadn't
got there but i'm proud of you for
saying enough so i tell you i i admire
your courage maggie
not only to sit down and do that but
also to tell the story right now
because it's so valuable you don't know
how many people you're helping at this
moment telling the story
because it is it's somewhere around 30
to 35
of spouses are hiding debt from their
that's one one out of three marriages
are hiding debt and it's just it's it's
it eats your soul up inside it's your
stomach up you you're walking ulcer and
and curtis can't figure out what's wrong
why can't connect why is why isn't why
is he failing as a husband why you can't
get this moving why this relationships
thing's not working and then she comes
clean goes oh now i understand i may
kill her but i'm gonna understand you
know and then fast forward and now
you're completely debt free what does
that feel like you did that together wow
so powerful
yeah i mean it it feels
incredible to just be able to
you know make purchases and not have to
worry about it i mean
curtis uh right afterwards when we made
the last payment um that week he was
like man i feel a little bit taller and
no joke tons of people started
commenting
at um just how tall he looked
like i was i felt like i was standing
two inches dollar yeah wow you were
literally well you're not carrying all
this sixty thousand bucks around on your
back yeah and you're not carrying around
the separation in your marriage you're
together and you've accomplished this
great goal together man what a cool
story and a 10-year anniversary woo-hoo
i love it you guys are success man
well done
you're both incredible okay so how much
does the makeup artist thing pay as a
side gig did you do good with that
yeah so that was where um the freelance
makeup artistry that i was doing where
we had that jump in income so that um 10
000
came from that
okay wow so you do well doing that okay
not a bad not a bad side gig to have if
you can get the work covet has messed up
a lot of the
event things out there obviously and so
a lot of people aren't the in the in
that world that do anything around
production including makeup um aren't
haven't had the work that they used to
have
and uh i know we had a lady in here that
they were doing a shoot and she said she
hadn't worked hardly at all and she was
happy to get the work to be in here
and uh so very cool congratulations you
guys
wow what do you tell people the key to
getting out of debt is
so uh
i think the biggest key and we kind of
talked about this earlier was
once everything was out in the open
and
we were actually working together she
wasn't holding back
um i
i really think that was a huge key and
our our marriage is better because of it
sure
and personally
i uh
like she said i listen to the show all
the time
anytime i hear one of your quotes or
sayings or bible verses i actually have
a huge list
in my phone and sometimes i'll look to
that
for motivation that's cool well i'm
honored thank you
we're going to send you a copy of baby
steps millionaire that's the next
chapter in your story and of course a
copy total money makeover so you can
disrupt someone's life 64 000 paid off
at 15 months making 90 to 100 maggie and
curtis i'm so proud of both of you
count it down let's hear a debt-free
scream
three two one
what a great story i love it
neat people it's awesome this is the
ramsay shot
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Music]
dr john dolone ramsey personality is my
co-host open phones at
825-5225 harrison's in boone north
carolina hi harrison welcome to the
ramsey show
hey dave hey dr john thank you for
taking my call sure what's up
yeah so i'm pretty dead set on trying to
open up a gym in my town this year
i've got about three hundred thousand
dollars uh set in investments and
savings
uh i'm 24 i'm totally debt free i have
no credit card debt no student loans no
car payment devil did you get 300 000
at 24 years old
well i've been working hard and
when i was a teenager i actually made
some really smart investment decisions
and
on top of that you know my grandma
passed away probably a year and a half
ago and i got about 50 000 from that
but everything else has just been
plotting and scheming along the way
honestly
wow
good for you amazing
that's mind-blowing way to go i'm so
proud of you
and so you're going to open a gym what
are you going to spend to open the gym
yeah so right now i have a budget of 100
000 but that comes down to my question
my question right now is should i bite
the bullet and and sell off some of my
investments and pay that capital gains
tax or
should i borrow against my current
investment assets
and
pay that borrowed money off
you know as soon as i possibly can
you should use the money from your
investments or you should not do the
deal
okay there's two benefits to that
there's three benefits to that
benefit number one that you don't see
coming and i saw it coming because when
i was your age i went deeply in debt
buying real estate became a millionaire
by the time i was 26.
okay and then lost it all because i had
too much debt
um so uh
the benefit that you don't realize and i
didn't realize it until i was in my 30s
because it was before then before i
started doing it when you start doing a
business investment
with money
that you place an emotional value on
that's your investments it's emotional
for you to pull 50 or 100 000 out of
those investments that you've
uh
worked your way so hard up into would
you agree with that statement
uh yeah it was yeah here's what's weird
here's what's weird is you will get
20 to 30
more purchasing power using your money
than you will borrowed money because
you're a little bit pissed about using
it
it hurts more than to use your money
than to use borrowed money so you're
more careful and wise with it and you'll
get a better buy you'll go you know what
i don't need that piece of equipment
right now let's find out if this is
going to work i'll i'll do that in my
phase two and by the way you do need to
open this gym in two phases
you don't need to just open it like you
know what you're doing because you've
never done this before
because some of the things you think are
gonna work aren't gonna work and i don't
want you spending a bunch of money on
them until you've operated the gym a
little while
yeah understood um
i'm right now i also work three jobs
right now i'm i'm a full-time realtor
and then i have two other side jobs that
bring in some extra cash on top of that
and i'd like to still be doing real
estate as often as i can while i'm
operating the gym
so i will kind of have those two
means of income coming in
which is
kind of the entire reason i thought
about potentially borrowing the cash in
the first place and i would have a mean
to pay off quickly nope if you're not
willing to put your money in it don't do
it
yes sir it's a commitment thing man so
number one is you're gonna be wiser with
the money number two is you're lowering
your level of risk and your potential
for success is increased on the gym
because you don't have the strain of
paying the note
you're 24 you made 300 000 bucks that's
unbelievably awesome i love it i'm happy
for you i'm proud of you if you burn
100k of it and you screw this whole
thing up your life ain't over it ain't
even close to over you still got 200
grand you still got a wonderful thing
ahead of you and you still got that head
on your shoulders which is actually the
secret sauce
uh yeah you're right i couldn't agree
more yeah with a hundred thousand dollar
investment that's gonna buy you about
seven dumbbells these days right
maybe yeah eight eight dumbbells with
the price of gym equipment these days
yeah it's probably difficult to get this
thing funded um real difficult yeah yeah
i i really would ease into this i i
would open it uh with a minimal
version one
though with a plan that at six months
i'm gonna take it to version two and
it's six months more and we'll take it
to version three as a proof text meaning
i prove out some of the systems
processes marketing that you're gonna
use in this thing because opening a gym
in a coveted environment is a uh it's a
high risk environment man and and buying
it now and opening it in four months is
going to put you behind the curve when
people start even joining gyms right so
is this something you can put off for a
year save a little bit more money or
whatever that looks like but
yeah before this is learning the
business what percentage of people are
back what percentage aren't in your area
i'd say my guess is boone's pretty open
uh it's probably like our area we're
completely open as if nothing's going on
in our area um but uh
but you know the the uh the fear porn
that's uh surrounding corvid kova that's
out there it's being hammered out of dc
and being hammered in the media because
it's really good for the media to scare
the crap out of you all the time helps
their ratings it's kind of like tornado
warnings right um
and so yeah you just you know you you
got all that that same business
environment you're operating in and you
don't want to add risk to that with debt
and and you're in a high risk space
you're going into
uh i mean the number of gyms that open
and fail is almost all of them in a good
in a good year here in a high-risk space
yeah it's like a restaurant business
it's a tough business the last thing
i'll tell you is this i uh i understand
your reasoning that you want to run the
gym and stay in the real estate business
running a business starting in a small
business and running it that has a lot
of hours of open to the public
uh is going to require your presence
it's going to require your focus so i
don't think you're going to be doing a
lot of real estate in the year you open
the gym
i think you're going to be doing a lot
of gym
i think you're going to be there a lot
you're going to be sweeping the floors
you're gonna be setting up the chairs
and resetting the dumbbells and
sanitizing stuff and you're gonna be
doing all you're gonna be working your
butt off man
and uh uh
you know if you wanna be in the real
estate business being the real estate
business but anything with two heads is
a monster bifurcating your focus is a
good way to cause failure
so i'm going to recommend you plan on
doing very little real estate till you
get that gym up and running and it's
making so much money that you can afford
to put an operational manager in there
where you don't have to be there all the
time
but you can't do that till you get the
thing running it's up to you this is
your baby you better rock it
and pay cash for it or don't do it
thanks for the call
open phones at triple eight eight two
five five two two five dr john deloney
is here we're talking relationships
we're talking money
john this is uh um
you know hey uh let's send him a copy of
uh if he's still on the line i think he
is send him a copy andre leadership
and le the our our our playbook on how
to run and start and run a small
business
the way we run this one here how we've
grown this from a card table in my
living room to where it is today
so this whole thing of uh
a guy that ticks like that that's 24.
then amazing
that's pretty cool yeah he's a high
performance guy
yeah he's most 24 year olds in the
country don't know what capital gains
are yeah
and uh uh but he's running about three
different
angles here at all times and he's done
something with the investing i didn't
get into what it was that that worked um
the danger
having been that guy
because i'm a bit of a math math is my
thing you know
and so uh i was that guy i was way ahead
of the curve
when i was his age uh thus i was a
millionaire but i was 26 and i had you
know hundreds of properties and so forth
done
probably today i think i've owned over
2000 pieces of real estate in my life so
i mean i was early
uh
adopter or early uh whatever perform you
know or beyond my years or that kind of
thing in the early days and uh but
there's something going on with that guy
that uh
he's not only got an abundance mentality
but he's just gone he there there's some
extra motor running there yeah and the
challenge there is to not mistake your
past success for invincibility hubris
always still every new job every project
every new job you start over with the
humility at square one and build it back
up yeah right you're learning something
new every time yeah it's gonna take
twice as long costs twice a month yeah
it's going to be 100 000 less than that
he learns on this one and then you pick
up the next or maybe he makes a million
dollars and crushes it man maybe becomes
the next um
whatever chain of gems and it could
happen i hope so for him yeah absolutely
that puts this hour of the ramsey show
in the books
i'm dave ramsey dr john dolone ramsey
personality is my co-host
[Music]
have a friend or family member that
needs a daily dose of ramsay advice in
their life let them know about the
ramsey call of the day podcast it's a
quick hit of advice about life and money
in under 10 minutes check out the ramsey
call of the day podcast wherever you
listen to podcasts
[Music]
this is the ramsay show
[Music]
you can be intentional about your
character you can have money and a
career
you are the hero in your story
[Music]
live from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions it's the ramsey show where
debt is dumb cash is king and the paid
off home mortgage has taken the place of
the bmw as the status symbol of choice
i'm dave ramsey your host thank you for
joining us america we're glad you're
here dr john deloney ramsey personality
is my co-host today this is the show
where we talk about your work
your relationships your life and your
money and how they all work together
whether you want them to or not open
phones at triple eight eight two five
five two two five susie's in minneapolis
hi susie welcome to the ramsay show
hi dave and john thanks for taking my
call sure what's up okay
my 90 year old parents moved into an
independent care apartment
um their house that they have lived in
for 65 years is now vacant for the last
year and a half
it's in their will that it would get
divided up between six people
they currently don't need the money
should we sell it now or wait
that's a
an emotional thing in it
yes yeah how long have they been in uh
the independent care
it's been a year and a half
are they both um how are they doing with
their uh
cognitive are they are they both of
right mind
yes they're
they have each other so
my dad you know what watches out for my
mom
they get along well
um
all their needs are met what do they
what do they think about selling the
home
well for the longest time my dad never
you know he bought it in 1955 he's
doesn't want to sell
and now he's they're realizing of course
that they're never going to go back
right um
so
i don't think he wants to sell but he's
starting to think about it
okay
well they don't need the money so
there's no hurry
and as long as they are capable of
making the decision it's their decision
to make
yes and i would let him come to his own
come come to this conclusion on your own
it sounds like he's the kind of guy that
just takes him a little while to come to
the
it would take me a little while if i was
him
yeah to come to the reality turning
loose of that is like part of admitting
you're you're not gonna make it in this
life and by the way that we all aren't
gonna make it we know that but you know
there's something emotional to
that when he releases that it's like
it's like sitting down doing a will it's
like admitting i'm gonna die
is there one of the six who of your you
know is one of your brothers and sisters
that is saying they want this house
when oh no nobody wants the house okay
okay the one thing i don't like is
people leaving real estate to multiple
parties i've never seen that not be a
mess yeah i'd go ahead and sell it as
soon as he's able to do that emotionally
okay there's no it's not doing anything
it's just sitting there and as you said
the the poignant words but their real
words is they're not going back there
and just when you say that outside out
loud it hurts your heart a little bit i
don't even know you guys hurts my heart
a little bit
it's hard you know
but uh um i mean you know it's just
that's what you're saying you're saying
dad and mom are gonna die someday oh my
god i don't want to say that out loud
but that's the truth
and inside that house is that for half a
century there's so many memories and
joys and laughters and tears that's hard
yeah it's very hard it's a very hard
it's a very emotional decision as far as
the real estate and the financial part
of the decision it's pretty simple it's
sitting there making no money it's it's
going to be a mess for the six of you to
sell and have to deal with later after
they pass it's much cleaner for everyone
if you go ahead in terms of the
financial aspect go ahead and sell it
now
but i don't want to
walk through your grief with my muddy
boots and say you have to do that
instantaneously
so i would do it as soon as he is
able and in other words dad when you're
ready to sell it i'm ready to help you
but i'm not gonna push you dad because i
understand how much of your heart is in
those hardwood floors
okay yeah that's kind of where it
is right now yeah but i'm gonna ask you
about it dad not i'm gonna lovingly and
kindly ask you about it to make sure
you're processing this decision
but when you're ready i'm ready to help
you and i'm gonna cry just like you are
okay yeah that's me talking to him if
i'm you
yep got it makes sense
yes it does yeah let's get rid of it as
soon as we can get the emotional part
the the the grieving of the that phase
of life is never going to be again
there's never going to be another
christmas tree from your family in that
living room
and uh boy if i don't put a tear in your
eye i don't know who you are well
there's some something about just seeing
that stuff out loud oh man right and you
can feel it and it's out there but it's
separate from you and you get to you're
going to do all this we do all this
macabre humor with my family yeah you
know so like we have a meeting every
year the if dave dies meeting the
wednesday of day if dave dies this year
here's what happens with the company
here's what happens with real estate
here's where we are it's it's like a
status quo and if in the next 12 months
dave dies this is what it is and i call
it the monty python meeting you know i'm
feeling much better it's just a flesh
wound you know but it just makes you it
just makes you say out loud your
mortality yeah and yes man it's it's
wicked weird that's why i have to joke
about it because it's just awkward and
uncomfortable oh yeah i have to push it
off with humor but oh my gosh but i
remember my granddad sold his home that
he'd been in 40 50 years
and
he's quietly sent checks to his kids
and as
as a this was gonna happen then this
happened i went ahead and took care of
this now and there was something
powerful and he was an engineer he's a
pragmatic but it was something powerful
about
here's a reality that we're all facing
and this was every bit of part of
y'all's life as it was mine i went ahead
and took care of this for you i took
care of it and exchanged cash in the
driveway with some guy and it's just a
cool
story there and that and that's hard and
it took years to get there but man
you know i i knew a guy that was a
pastor that was african-american guy
that was a friend of my pastors and a
friend of mine as well
my first pastor and
he turned
i think he turned 88 or something like
that and he was driving to the grocery
store and he realized that
i'm that guy
i'm the slowest guy i'm the old man in
traffic oh no
and i'm gonna cause a wreck uh cause he
said i looked up and i realized on my
way you know two miles to the grocery
store and two miles back i had swerved
into the other lane twice and he goes
i've become that old man and he and and
i thought it's the most manly thing i've
ever heard anybody do
that a man steps up at 88 years old and
he dropped the keys in the bowl at his
daughter's house and he said i'm not
driving anymore so the car wow
he said he's self-aware
but i mean that's that requires humility
and vulnerability and strength the level
of courage
to me that was just like conan the
barbarian dropping those keys in that
bowl man that was just um
because that
that's a level of self-awareness very
few people have well it's one step
beyond that i think a lot of us have
self-awareness we're honest what we see
in the mirror we know he but he went did
something about it and that's the well
it was a permanent yeah it was not like
for the weekend
it's not like i had too much to drink
tonight
no it's like i'm never driving again in
my life
that's a
[Music]
this is this is the real stuff you guys
this is the ramsay show
[Music]
if you're looking for ways to update
your home without blowing the budget
i've got it for years i've been telling
you about our friends at blinds.com
blinds.com makes it simple to shop top
quality blinds shades and interior
shutters from home with easy online
ordering and free shipping with
blinds.com there's no need to renovate
your entire home just change out what's
on your windows with upscale choices
like faux wood blinds cellular and
roller shades or even outdoor shades
plus blinds.com guarantees the perfect
fit whether you do it yourself or you
have them measure and install everything
for you shop their latest looks and see
how much you can save at blinds.com
today the easy and affordable way to
make your home more beautiful is
blinds.com
[Music]
well i am excited i'm
didn't think i was gonna be excited but
i am actually excited i have a new book
coming out congratulations i haven't
done a book in eight years a major trade
book uh last one it was smart many smart
kids with rachel i was in high school
eight years ago man that's really i'm
not really i just lied to you yeah you
do
i've told you a million times quite
exaggerating congratulations man i'm
excited for you
thanks i am excited it's selling very
very well in pre-sale it's going to be a
seller of course
and baby steps millionaires but i'm
really excited about it is i think i
really
did what i set out to do which is make
the case that if you're listening to the
sound of my voice right now you can be a
millionaire and i can show you how
and
not that being a millionaire matters
but being able to pay for
oh i don't know move into
assisted living and
not have to sell the house because
you're broke yeah you know that matters
yep you know that last call right uh
that kind of you got choices yeah when
you got some money or your spouse passes
away and you don't you can grieve and
you can spend time well and and you can
you know take all your grandkids and
load them up and take them on a cruise
and you can uh buy a bunch of uh food
for hungry people and you can buy some
shoes for people that don't have shoes
and you could buy a single mom a car and
you can't do that when you're broke i've
noticed so
um
we want to show you how to be
outrageously generous and be in a
position to be outrageously generous and
that's what baby steps millionaire is
all about i'm really really excited
about what this book is going to do it's
again it's already
sold a bazillion copies i'm really
thankful thank you to all of you you
guys make these things best sellers for
all of us that work here and we we
really appreciate it we appreciate the
opportunity to serve you so babysits
millionaires comes out next week you can
still get it on pre-sale for 20. if you
buy it before next week like right now
in other words you'll get the audio book
and the e-book free and the legacy
journey which is a little book i did on
wealth audio book and ebook for free
and uh baby steps millionaires live
stream of course is next thursday and
the live stream is free whether you buy
the book or not ramsey smart tax you'll
get that as well and that means that you
can do your income tax filing online for
free and 30 days of ramsey plus access
to financial peace university and every
dollar for free all for twenty dollars
it's not free it's for twenty dollars
but you got the book twenty dollar book
for twenty dollars so the other stuff is
thrown in that makes it free yeah that's
that's how it really works so get all of
that at ramseysolutions.com in the store
it's pretty easy to do ramsay
solutions.com
jump in there and make that part of it
our question today comes from blinds.com
they have a 100
satisfaction guarantee if you mismeasure
you mess up you pick the wrong color
they'll remake the blinds for free who
does that a great american company like
blinds.com
yeah you get free samples free shipping
the new promos they run every month you
save even more
use the promo code ramsey to get the
best possible deal today's question
comes from ellie in california ellie
writes since moving in with my boyfriend
of six years i've realized that his
parents are extremely toxic
just now realizing that huh several
years ago exactly several years ago they
lost their business and home due to
money mismanagement and showed up on his
doorstep asking for a place to stay
over the years he has consistently put
their needs over his own by loaning
money allowing them to live with him for
free and having them work at his
businesses
since they started working for him he
discovered that his mother was writing
payroll checks to his father for work he
never completed ordering parts for their
cars on his business account and my
boyfriend has been sued by a customer
for 15 grand
because of his father's mistakes
they will never take responsibility for
any of this and he will not confront
them i really care about him but
something is telling me to run yeah i
agree run yeah two other people are
telling you to run go
run
there's three of us now you dave me
everybody run
should i stay and continue to help him
establish boundaries or run as fast i
can run as fast you can you can't solve
that problem period and it's
and and and let me help you with this
too i'm going to be really mean okay i'm
just going to be really blunt shuckler
okay shock alert yeah
just let's but i want to warn you ahead
of time before i do it okay
if after six years of dating him you
didn't realize this
you do not have the relational tools to
enter into this toxic disaster and be of
any good absolutely that's not rude you
are naive yes and that's being kind
blind
intentionally so
yes
yeah
denial is not a river in egypt exactly
oh my gosh um yeah ron you you um
yeah here's the thing this is a
complicated relational psychological
disaster that's going to require
a long time and a lot of professional
help to untwine
and you don't want to be there right
this is a there's a this this is
this is the worst part of the for better
for worse thing you don't want to be
there
uh because
the problem is not his parents
the problem is his unwillingness to deal
it with it and your blindness
intentional blindness towards the whole
thing now we've got four people in this
four-person story all misbehaving
so including you what does this look
like six years of
relationship plus a home
so you you sit down and say there's a
high probability you don't make it like
90 something oh probability just doesn't
make it so do you sit down and tell him
hey
here's the deal you got
or are you just out i i just don't like
you anymore i mean i'm going i mean it's
just i don't like you anymore i'm just
i'm done i don't know whatever it is you
have to say i don't know how to break up
i haven't broken up in 40 years
i don't like that anymore i don't like
you anymore i'm done but i mean yes but
i mean
i would just say you know what i've come
to realize looking at this that this
thing is too big a mess for me to
participate in and i'm scared
and i've got to leave because i'm scared
yeah which would actually be the truth
if you're smart if you're smart enough
to be scared
it's the truth and i'm not this that
this is just grandpa advice sitting
beside the psychologist okay
um well whatever it is you are yeah i'm
not one of those but not the doctor i'm
not smart enough but i i'll tell you dr
dr dalony yes it's time to go time to go
and my guess is you know this
you know you wouldn't know she wouldn't
ask i mean
she knows she she mapped it out she
knows yeah this is this is here's the
other way you can ask the question i
love this one i heard somebody do this
one time and it it made a lot of sense
to me it's
if you had a daughter
and she sat down at your knee
and said the guy i just moved in with
that that did that fill in the blank
what would you tell your daughter yes
run yes well yeah that's what you tell
her and never mistake this
just because it hurts doesn't mean it's
not the right thing and just because
you're gonna miss him doesn't mean it's
not the right thing but it's time to go
there's some good parts of this or you
wouldn't have hung around yeah yep time
to go but there are but you didn't list
any of those
geez there's nothing else on the scale
in this email except
he's a business owner he's kind i mean
he's probably got some great quality
yeah he's yeah he's an enabler
uh like world class apparently uh daniel
is in
atlanta hi daniel welcome to the ramsay
show
holy moly i gotcha you did you sir we
got you what's up
be careful what you wish for
the third i can't even believe it
listen
i wanted to call and thank you
three weeks ago
i stumble on you i'm watching some car
blog
and some guy mentions dave ramsey oh
i've heard that name so for the last
three weeks i've been i've been binging
your blog oh my gosh and man i have just
learned so much about and just listening
to people's experiences
and you know so many things i can relate
to a lot of things
in your life dave
um you and i are the exact same age oh
wow well daniel we are honored and i i
really appreciate all that i am up
against the clock and i want to make
sure i answer your question here we go i
don't want to be rude i'm 60 i'm 61.
nothing really we got 25 000
to our name we are 100 debt free
three weeks ago i had 100 grand in the
bank i took it i paid off the mortgage
we owe nothing to no one
what's your household income we've got
about
i'm sorry i couldn't hear you what's
your household income
uh
let's call it 100. okay so how fast are
you going to build your retirement now
that you don't have a payment in the
world
well i i want to build it quickly and
that's why i'm calling if you had some
other than the you know reaching out to
the ramsey people which i did i did
exactly spoke to five different ones
i wanted to get some specific
recommendations for funds from you
if it's in your book i'll wait i ordered
two of your books for my boys i
appreciate it i don't do specific fund
recommendations because that's the
equivalent of an endorsement of a
particular fund instead we teach you the
concepts and we let you go use those
concepts to do your investing
daniel we're so honored to have you in
the audience now so great get in touch
with the smartvestor pro sit down you
are on the right track you're going to
be amazing
[Music]
[Music]
dr john deloney ramsey personalities my
co-host today
joining us for a debt free scream is
seth from cheyenne wyoming hey seth how
are you
doing well thanks dave it's casper
actually oh i'm so sorry
i'll work on my spelling here okay good
so uh how much debt have you paid off
165 000 very good and how long did that
take you
it took uh seven years from the time i
started paying it off
um
it was a long road um
and it took us a long time i know your
average is probably a lot shorter than
that but uh
cancer um kind of got in the way but we
still did it oh man whoa
okay what was your range of income
during that seven years
um anywhere from 75 up to 100. okay so
tell me about cancer getting in the way
um
well as you know medical bills are
expensive and and cancer took my life
that's oh my goodness oh man i'm so
sorry seth when she passed away that was
about six months ago oh what was her
name
sierra sierra beautiful wow
yeah
so
you know
she was
excuse me
um she was my rock you know yeah
um
yeah and uh
stuff got expensive
and we were trying to make her student
it was all student loans by the way yeah
um
and when it got tough i was like you
know we don't have to make that payment
this month we could do a reduced payment
she was no we're making the whole
payment
so she kept us going and and uh and
about a month after she passed i got it
paid off and and she'd be happy that
we're here doing this
wow i've seen a picture of her up on
youtube what a beautiful beautiful
family
yeah how old was you thank you
35 oh my gosh sir
i'm so sorry
yeah you uh
uh
getting out of debt is way down the list
of things to do when you were fighting
cancer
um yeah and and so i agree with you on
that and um
so if you uh
if you have to put things on hold or put
uh
delay things or slow things or whatever
during that kind of a battle that's
uh that's what you should do you you
should take care of your family before
you worry about this other stuff
we want you to get out of debt because
it's good for your family but my
goodness gracious wow
yeah but you also you also had a
a wife who was like you said you're a
rock and man i've i've been around a few
folks who are fighting cancer and they
the fighter comes out like we're
finished in this journey where we
started right it sounds like who she was
oh yeah and she just
she wouldn't let me quit and you know we
stayed on it and
you know and i should say you know
dave you changed our lives you know um
we got on we you know we got life
insurance and that's really how we paid
off the last 17 of 165 is i had a life
insurance policy and it
took the burden off
after she was gone and and i'm glad we
did that because
you know i i guess
it's part of her legacy that you know
now that
um she's gone
you know we we did that now i can share
that with my kids and
and
they're um
you know they weren't forgotten yeah
it's part of the story
it's part of your story and um
it's a beautifully sad story yeah
and um
well good wow
absolutely amazing
absolutely amazing so how old are your
kiddos
i have a 13 year old and a nine year old
so what got what got you and her on this
journey you and sierra on this journey
seven years ago
well um
it was after i graduated um from school
um
i i'm an optometrist and i got out of
optometry school then i did a residency
during that residency
i deferred my loans for a year
and i watched it i watched it go from
155 to 165
yeah because i wasn't making payments
i'm like what you got to be kidding me
that's what interest does to you
these were your student loans
yes they were all mine
that she's fighting to pay off oh my
gosh
yeah and so
we uh um
i watched that happen and and then of
course dave you're on the radio as as
i'm driving home from work every day and
you know what eventually it just becomes
contagious and
it's like let's get this done
and then she was definitely more of the
gazelle intense as you put it than i was
but i brought it up and she ran with it
wow
well way to go man way to go thank you
so have uh the kids got a clear
understanding they're old enough
of uh
how this debt-free thing weaves into the
story with their mom
yeah i think so okay you know they're
they're gonna know it by the time they
leave the house
well it's their legacy it's part it's
part of our story now
that's woven into her into them
and it's part of something she cared
about and uh it's part of the memory and
part of the legacy and the whole thing
so it's really really important that the
family tree has changed here in the
midst of this tragedy
and uh so wow absolutely amazing amazing
so what are their names
uh porter's my 13 year old and lilia is
my nine-year-old all right very cool
very cool i i just want to just man
seth
what a what an incredible way to honor
your wife
by finishing the journey
you know what i mean and when you get
married you set out on a journey
together and it ends and and
we all know it ends for us all of us but
it ends at play in times and ways and
places we'll never expect
and brother you kept going and you
finished the journey how what a we talk
about her legacy what a legacy you've
left for me for the all the listeners
for your kids
good for you for honoring your wife in
that way and putting a period into that
sentence for your whole family that's
just brilliant man
thank you it's awesome pretty incredible
all right it's seth and sierra porter
and lilia all from casper wyoming 165
000 paid off in seven years
making 75 thousand to a hundred
count it down let's hear a debt-free
scream
three two one
[Applause]
[Music]
well we've got a copy of baby steps
millionaires that will send you and
that's the next chapter
in this story
uh there's a future
in this story just like there's a past
in this story
and uh we want to be part of that bright
future as well
so also i can send you a copy total
money makeover so you can give that to
someone in the process and uh
pretty pretty incredible
oh she was young
too young way too young
man way to you
you're just here for a vapor ah
yeah that tombstone thing man when you
look at those two dates on a tombstone
you got the beginning
yep you got the end yeah when you go to
heaven when you graduate
and the question the old motivational
speaker always asks is what are you
going to do with that dash huh i never
heard that before what are you going to
do with that dash
and uh
i was speaking at a funeral for a friend
of mine that passed a little while back
and
uh
me and uh mansfield steve mansfield were
both speaking at this guy we're good
friends of both of them and mansfield
said something i'll never forget he said
a funeral is a tuning fork
just like a birth there's a tuning fork
for your life when you go to a funeral
you know when you leave a funeral or
even a wedding too you go home you go i
need to readjust yeah i had a buddy i
need to readjust
that calm helps me remind yeah i need to
readjust i need to make sure i'm in
and you people listening you need to
freaking readjust absolutely yeah you
listen to those guys that's about as
motivational a call as i've had in a
long time yeah i had a buddy pass away
this last week and uh named chris and
the number of people who came back to be
with him and to be at that funeral it i
love the idea of a funeral being a way
to just say just like a birthday says i
love you when you're here if you're
one's a way to say i love you when
you're gone yup and it's a beautiful
testimony good job seth what a stud man
man amazing
this is the ramsey show wow
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
our scripture today psalm 113 3 from the
rising of the sun to the place where it
sets the name of the lord is to be
praised
jim rhodes said either you run the day
or the day runs you
dr john deloney ramsey personality is my
co-host today as we talk about your life
and your money kim is in boise idaho hi
kim welcome to the ramsay show
hi dave thanks for taking my call sure
what's up
um i have a term life insurance question
i have a
highly disabled daughter who will
require
um care her whole life and i guess we're
just wondering if you would approach
life insurance differently in that
situation where we'll have to be
i mean technically the government might
provide care for her at some point but
we also may be needing to pay for help
with her for the rest of her life
i mean the house should be paid off but
i guess
in typical situations you
don't have to pay for that so if one of
us were to die we would have to hire
care for her
forever so yeah what's your advice in
that scenario
it doesn't change it just takes a
highlighter marker and puts on our
advice it makes it very very super
important as if it's not already
important so let me kind of walk you
through without special needs and then
let's come back to your special needs
okay
so our normal advice is 15 to 20 years
worth of level term insurance during
that 15 to 20 years you would have paid
off your home because we tell you not to
have more than 15-year mortgage you will
have gotten out of debt and began
investing 15 of your household income
into retirement during that 15 to 20
years you probably are going to end up
with 700 800 000 in mutual funds a paid
for house and during that 15 to 20 years
your kids would grow up and leave the
last part's what's different right
right so you still have to get the rest
of that going though
you're still working we've done all that
you still work you if you're if you're
funding retirement
you know you keep life insurance and you
keep life insurance in place until you
have enough money
instead of life insurance to leave in
trust for her to be taken care of so how
much is in your retirement account
um retirement i think we have
around
500 or 700 thousand
um that'd be a number you need to know
closer than that
i know i didn't ask
i didn't look it up so i called but i
mean you just need to know you need to
know that number
you don't have to know it to the penny
but 500 to 700 is a pretty big spread so
how old are you guys
uh 37 okay
so
let's just run normal scenario okay if
you run a normal scenario and you guys
keep investing in retirement and you get
your house paid off
and both of you die
in your 60s
which is really our question here okay
let's take a 15-year policy that puts
you to
uh
52 right
that puts you to 52. okay
at 52 you're gonna have a million two in
mutual funds a million four in mutual
funds in your retirement and you should
be having close to a paid for house by
then if not having paid for agreed
correct yeah okay
now if you pass away at 52 which would
mean you would die very very early both
of you died early
okay
if you leave your retirement account and
the house is sold and you leave that
into a trust to be taken care of
for your child the trustee has close to
two million dollars
that the income off of the two million
dollars will easily take care of your
child with no life insurance
okay
so it does not change our life insurance
advice because the life insurance advice
is to keep term insurance in place until
you're debt-free and you have enough
assets in place to take care of the
people left behind typically that's a
spouse we're referring to because the
kids are grown and gone or they're
little kids one of the two
but in your case you've got this
perpetual need
beyond the two of you passing to take
care of the special needs so it's called
a special needs trust
and it's a part of your will
and it's formed upon the second person
to die
and all of your assets are poured into
that trust with direct and detailed
instructions to the trustee of how you
want them invested
and how they're how and under what
circumstances they're to be paid out
beyond the income and to who they would
be paid out to and so forth how the
child's to be cared for
right but i mean couple hundred thousand
dollars a year will take care of this
kid
and that's what you're gonna have at 52.
okay
so your need for life insurance to
supplement that goes away as your wealth
increases and your debt decreases do you
see how i'm doing that
yeah what's the nature of the special
need
uh cerebral palsy okay cool all right
and how how boy or girl
a girl how old is she now
eight
okay cool
i've got a niece uh cp
it's a beautiful beautiful person it's
30
in a wheelchair and so my brother and
sister-in-law are facing the exact same
kinds of things uh she just has gone out
and is living on her own for the first
time they didn't think she'd do that be
able to do that so it's a wonderful
victory story we're proud of her
and i'm proud of them for letting her
it's hard it's hard to do
but uh but yeah it's a it's a process
and uh how severe is your cp
she will be dependent forever no i i
know that i understood that part i'm
just saying is she wheelchair right
she's non-verbal yeah she's non-verbal
non-mobile okay all right
okay
well you guys you guys got a real battle
on your hands and you you're you're very
brave people congratulations and
uh god gives a special measure of
strength to to people he gives these
assignments to
so you're you're beautiful we appreciate
you and we appreciate you calling in and
who you are and anytime we can help you
we will but get a will done with a
special needs trust pour your assets
into that until you have assets you pour
the term life insurance into that and
that'll take care of your baby
and uh and you give very clear specific
instructions as to how it's to be
invested and how the proceeds off of the
investments are to be used for the care
uh it's very detailed and for the rest
of you by the way that have children
that you're not facing that with you can
do the same thing for minor children
and that when my children were minors
john that's how our will was set up
upon our death there's a children's
trust
that's mine too not today because our
children are grown but uh when they were
minors and then not only who the
guardian is going to be but a different
person is the trustee and and i want you
in my case i said i want you to invest
in the four types of mutual funds we
talk about growth growth and income
aggressive growth and the income has
pulled off and for again we're talking
about minor children
you know that don't do not have a
special need then we just said okay you
can pull the money off in addition to
the income that's used to take care of
the kids
they if there needs to be some other
withdrawals it could be for buying a
first car within reason it could be for
paying for college it could be for major
medical that pops up but otherwise you
keep your hands off of it and you let it
grow and you let the nest egg produce
the income
lay the golden eggs that take care of
the babies gotcha and that's how it's
set up and and you can fund that with
life insurance until you have enough
money in your retirement to cause it to
pour over into that and it's your
secondary beneficiary on your retirement
your first beneficiary is your spouse
but if both of you are gone what we're
talking about your secondary beneficiary
is named that family trust so in this
new year
get a will
absolutely get a will and get yours
updated too by the way i talked to a guy
the other day had gone through a divorce
and didn't ever update his will
so his ex-wife still
the chief beneficiary of all of his
assets you want to hear a fun court case
is trying to pry that one away from your
kids because you can't try to pry that
away from her to give to your kids oh
you won't
and she's the ex she won't and they're
her kids
that's incredible what a dessert get a
will and change your beneficiaries when
you go through a divorce my god
get it get stuff updated it's man you
just got to do business like you're
freaking adults or something don't
outsource your life plug back in
get it done
get a will
outsource your life there's a thing with
you today and i like it driving me crazy
it's it's a good phrase 20 22. it's a
good phrase don't outsource your life
don't don't don't let someone else live
your life for you
it's a it's it's the game boy generation
the nintendo generator generation yeah
yeah instead of really doing it we do it
on tv yeah we watch somebody else do it
on tv yeah gross
just gross just gross
oh man
all right that's good let's get a good
will in that right there yeah wow
what a show
dr john deloney
james childs
and jenna on the phones i'm dave ramsey
your host we'll be back with you before
you know it in the meantime remember
there's ultimately only one way to
financial peace and that's to walk daily
with the prince of peace christ jesus
[Music]
this is james childs producer of the
ramsay show you can listen to all our
shows with the ramsay network app on
your smartphone browse by topic or even
sync clips to your friends
download the ramsay network app in your
favorite app store today
[Music]
you